les petites mains s'affairent pour
préparer près 2 600 lantern réalisé
entièrement à la main et recouvertes de
tissu à la tombée de la nuit elle
s'illumine avec et cinq mille ampoules
led
les pièces sont fabriquées en asie gang
en chine où règne la tradition des
festival des lanternes
je suis allé deux fois à zig en titane
en mai et juillet pour discuter le
design du festival les aspects
techniques du projet et comment comment
réaliser toute la partie logistique du
festival
les pièces ont été transportés dans
dix-huit contenaires avant d'arriver au
zoo après être déballé les pièces sont
installés les visiteurs découvriront
près de 600 lantern plantes et animaux
lumineux pour finir au château une
grande scène renaissance en présence du
roi henri iv est au programme avec des
personnages inédits
on a un petit garçon qui fait partie du
sel renaissance sur le partage du
château avec son petit bras kate et son
balcon pour cette deuxième édition du
festival touahri lumière sauvage c'est
un nouveau parcours sur près de 3
hectares avec pour thématique la grande
odyssée de l'évolution 42 cents sont à
voir comme celle ci s'est débattu
de l'époque fin xvième siècle et ça
explique ça raconte pas l'histoire de la
coupe du monde de cette époque le
festival touahri lumière sauvage est à
découvrir du 27 octobre au 8 mars 2020
la première édition avait rassemblé près
250 mille personnes